solving education is not just a solving
education it's kind of solving
everything now if you care about aids in
Africa if you care about poverty in the
inner city if you care about the
environment whatever you care about you
care about education this is the
ultimate gateway problem I absolutely
believe that we need a revolution in
education and the good news is it very
much appears to be happening
the history of the human race is really
a history of Education great moments in
education have dominated the great
moments in history out of the Industrial
Revolution we took what we learned about
factories and processes and efficiencies
now we turned education to a giant
assembly line system you'd never build a
system like the one we have today if
you're building it from scratch it's a
crazy system it's intuitive that not
everybody has the exact same learning
style and works equally well for each
kid for each thing that they learn
education is very very slow to innovate
but when it does two things happen
there's a kind of a Cambrian explosion
of access increased access and also of
improved quality simultaneously I
believe that we're on the verge of the
next great jump and that's going to be
online education if we can suddenly mine
all of the data that you've always been
producing when you when you study we can
personalize education to you we work
with partners like publishers and
schools and we take their content we
make it adaptive you get your own
personal textbook it's literally unique
its creative every single day and within
a couple of weeks I know how strong you
are every single concept in the course
and I know exactly how you learn it best
if you learn math best in the morning
between 8 13 and 9 a.m. I know that if
you learn science best in 24 minute bite
sizes I know that
it's really personalized I mean there is
some belief that the education is not
just one on one but you do collaborate
if learning so kids learn from one
another you type a question into our
system our system can go we'll find
everybody who's online right this second
who absolutely knows the answer that
question and though he asked that
question to 15 people's pops up in their
screen and you get like the wisdom of
crowds harnessed with this adaptive a
eyes we can't teach the higher-level
critical thinking skills we can't build
the imaginations that's what the
teachers do online education is not
going to supplant traditional education
it's going to be a supplement to it now
if you have a great teacher in the room
with you obviously that's better
many people around the world don't we
want to expand education access as far
and wide as we can and that very much
includes in the developing world most of
the price of the textbook is just wasted
on paper and printing and shipping so I
believe we're on the verge of solving
the access problem for the developing
world we're gonna power about a million
students starting this fall in the
United States but very soon thereafter
we expect to start spreading all over
the world we want to make sure education
in the next decade or two becomes
available to everybody
anywhere in the planet it could well be
that the person who cures breast cancer
is growing up in some Cambodian fishing
village and will never be discovered the
world's best lecture notes on Hamlet
might be sitting on some desk top and
Dublin somewhere and shown to 30 kids a
year well we can actually unlock that
chap value for the first time
you